vous avez pris de bonnes résolutions
un groupe humain alors en france voici
l'interview bonnes résolutions de la
rentrée
olivia bonamy pour cette rentrée est ce
que vous avez décidé
d'arrêter de fumer
bon j'aimerais bien mais je suis une
petite fumeuse avance parce qu'en
général c'est juste des cigarettes de
plaisir d'accord
est ce que vous avez décidé de grossir
un peu pour donner une chance aux autres
filles
parce que à côté de vous ils ont peu de
chance
même si je mange beaucoup parce que je
manque beaucoup bon ben voilà ça me
prend pas toujours un peu la cua ouais
ça va
est ce que vous avez décidé de faire un
enfant ah oui ça de toute façon un jour
a pas cette année là
est ce que vous avez décidé d'arrêter de
vivre dans le péché non
vous avez décidé olivia bonamy cette
année de vous taper et jean yves le fur
comme toutes les autres filles
[Applaudissements]
de vous taper jean yves le fur comme
toutes les autres filles qui s abat vous
connaissez pas encore mais non il s'est
tapé tout les gonzesses 1 toutes les
actrices je pense que ça ne se passera
pas ça se passera pas par an est ce que
vous avez décidé cette année de prendre
un nom très connu pour avoir des rôles
encore meilleur
est ce que
est ce que vous êtes décidé d'arrêter
des émissions de télé à la con
bon moi je suis ici ce soir donc donc
non
alors en 2003 que thil de kuro qu'est ce
que vous avez décidé de plus faire
je sais pas de plus faire jouer chanter
ouais voulait plus santé oui et plus a
encore afin je veux la guitare
c'est bien qu'est-ce que vous êtes
décidé de ne plus faire en 2003 plus le
tout d'une plus faire du tout
j'ai du mal la saga si cette gamme on ne
fait pas dans sérieuse je serai pas avec
l'annoncé que je sais plus faire
donnez moi des exemples
s'il vous plaît enfin les choux pas
arrêtez de bancs d'école arrêté de boire
de l'alcool elle boit pas non mais c'est
vrai que je sais pas là la préoccupation
majeure c'est vrai que sais je suis un
peu venu dans cette émission je suis un
peu hein je suis très heureuse de te
parler des films de guillaume et du film
de jerry shen un paon mais je veux pas
faire ça quand même mls je voudrais être
je vous ai je pas si on forme de lancer
au lendemain danse est un peu et avant
d'isoler les lourds non non c'est pas du
tout ça c'est juste que je suis un peu
concerné par ce qui se passe en côte
d'ivoire personnellement et que c'est
difficile d'être là pour moi parce que
il y à il ya un pays qui est dans une
drôle de situation
j'y ai carrément coupée en deux non mais
c'est vrai en ce moment la guerre
maintenant j'ai vu qu'ils avaient des
rebelles encore ailleurs à l'ouest voilà
et que j'ai mon papa qui est là bas et
qui ne veut pas comme un homme qui est
sur un front et qui ne voudrait pas se
cacher sous terre ne veux pas revenir ou
trois bons
je suis un plein d'émotions mais
pourquoi il veut pas revenir dans
sérieux il sait que c'est dangereux
quand même non parce que je crois qu'il
est tombé follement amoureux de ce pays
et que
c'est sa vie tout simplement c'est
ouvert il est ingénieur conseil
la famille depuis longtemps qu'il y ait
donc les questions 2003 je voudrais
faire ci est ce que je voudrais faire ça
pour l'instant effectivement en 2003 que
ça se passe mieux pour tout le monde et
qu'on n'arrive pas tout ça est dans le
droit dans le mur et que tant qu'il ya
de l'appétit ya de la vie et qu'on en
profite au maximum avec générosité
simplicité voilà tout simplement
vous dites que vous êtes ingérable où
j'ai quand même pris quelques bonnes
résolutions pour 2006 j'espère on va
faire une interview bonnes résolutions
bon alors les bonnes résolutions 2006
est ce que vous allez arrêter de fumer
non est-ce que vous allez arrêter de
boire
est-ce que vous allez arrêter toute
drogue
est ce que vous allez faire un régime
non pas pour quoi faire est-ce que vous
avez bien sinon c'est vrai ce que vous
allez faire un septième enfant oui ah
oui
tu vas voir le prix cognac jane bingum
calais pour les contes de grimm à la
sphère les sept nains
lio est ce que vous allez mettre un
petit peu d'argent de côté
pour l'enfant pour le septième au moins
j'ai tellement de dette j'ai plutôt les
rendre obligatoires de fer lit-on oui
oui d'ailleurs excusé moi oui absolument
je signale que toutes les ventes de mon
disque dit au prince charmant sont
reversés à une fondation qui s'appelle
sauver les enfants de lio donc acheter
ce disque s'il vous plaît par milliers
parce que franchement ça va m'aider
énormément
si dragon de lancer une opération pièces
blanches de prévoir parce que les pièces
jaunes vous les fils adam chirac ce qui
reste dans votre poste de monnaie vous
les filets lio est décédé gros 500 - là
on sait vraiment où ça va et c'est assez
pour nourrir les petits et bien gérée
j'aimerais bien tu sais mais je sais
est ce que vous êtes tombée amoureuse
est ce que vous aller baiser comme une
folle
bassi veut bien est-ce que vous allez
reprendre le cinéma est ce que vous
allez faire des concerts ouais si vous
avez changé de coiffure non est-ce que
vous avez pas émettre des perruques a
comme moi
pas de copie la sauce je vais pas passer
celles que j'ai
moi je passerai ligne n ya pas de
problème se pose est est-ce que vous
avez vous réconcilier avec quelqu'un je
me reconstruis avec tout le monde moi
moi je n'ai pas de rancoeur je connais
pas ça est-ce que vous avez tiré un
trait sur certaines personnes
passent eux tirent un trait toute seule
elle même alors du coup j'ai plus
travaillé à faire oui est-ce que vous
avez corriger certains défauts
mais qu'est ce que j'ai comme défaut
terry aucun lieu au mas voilà quand on a
la solution comparable sur qui on des
philippines palau est ce que vous allez
faire la chirurgie esthétique and vous
avez pas besoin en même temps je pourrai
si elle a besoin comme tout le monde
mais non ça m'emmerde c'est long c'est
douloureux qu on a puis on n'a pas de
temps avant tout cas moi j'ai pas le
temps pour ça est ce que vous avez
couché les animateurs tv ah non non aux
chandelles qu'est ce qu'il ya comme
boîte de cul dans le 17ème offert
formidable alors je vais vous raconter
une anecdote si j'ai deux secondes
non parce que c'est quand même un des
trucs les plus humiliants qui me soit
arrivée de ma vie je tournais avec
gérard depardieu la fin de tenu de
soirée
gérard était en gare sont en cuir un
petit peu hyper maquiller moi j'étais en
travelo mais comme c'était comme c'était
entre deux prises contre y avait du
temps de réglage j'avais pas ma perruque
et j'avais des moonboots où ma jupe et
gérard ivre mort me dit je viens je vais
t'emmener dans un an une boîte sympa
l'avant là il ya un truc très sympa où
on a tombé avec le maurice pialat là tu
vas voir c'est vachement bien l'endroit
bien avec moi fillon gérard
il était déjà un petit peu avancé je me
suis dit on récupérera jamais ils n'ont
gérard on va pas aller si tu auras c'est
une boîte de cartouches tous un patois
nom gérard j'ai pas mes vieux non alors
il part et il part tout seul et je me
dis on va jamais retrouvé donc je lui
file le train on arrive une rue tout à
fait anonyme une porte cochère
d'immeubles très 17e
là une porte avec une entrée d'immeuble
normale et une petite porte dans le hall
de l'immeuble en face de l'ascension une
petite porte avec un judas donc tout ça
sont très très bons l'échangisme
gérard salle proche de l'âge d'or tu
sonnes et à ce moment là un monsieur
descend de son appartement 17e pas du
tout et j'en ris tu nous vois tous les
deux mois en jupe cette petite thierry
mugler qui valait si bien avec les
bombes ou les les fossiles maquillé
comme amérique sans perruque gérard en
cuir et nous regarde et il nous fait
vous allez là c'est coquin
je me suis dit il est parti je veux
suivre est composé de honte mais là
l'expression vous allez là c'est
qu'aucun dans le genre qui sont ensemble
ils vont s'envoyer en l'air lui en
travelo avec des moonboots et ça a été
l'humiliation la vie bat
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars
10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu
ce bleu